ce que vous misez sur le temps le temps
je pense à cela à des élections misez
vous sur se développent de gagner du
temps plus que de l'argent c'est sûr
qu'ils vont des élections au québec
d'ici 6 12 ou maximum 18 mois donc en ce
sens cela je pense que des avancées
importantes à court terme et c'est sûr
que si l'objectif qu'on s'est fixé les
chercher un gel des droits de scolarité
ou même une gratuité mais ce ça va
prendre un changement de gouvernement
c'est pas les libéraux actuelles qui
vont faire cette chose là et ça va
sûrement faire partie de la présentation
qu'on va donner aux étudiants avez vous
l'impression que les citations de la
motion monsieur zizian pour sont assez
fortes pour faire avorter l'acceptation
si l'offre 103 des citations qui sont
risqués à puidoux je cachais pas qu'on a
appris au cabinet de la ministre le
souhaitais il appelle l'ordre indiqué
que 1 en bouche à modérer ses
interventions futures parce qu'il me
semble que quand on sort d'une entente
comme celle là chacun des partis agi de
bonne foi on utilise un vocabulaire qui
est différent un certain temps qu'elle
passe parce que tout le monde
s'entendait autour de la table et
surtout du côté du trésor l'effet que
des gains d'efficience il y avait en
faire dans les universités même
directeur reconnaissent eux mêmes que
dans le processus de reddition de
comptes des universités il ya de
l'argent aller chercher et le maintenant
il faut que cet argent revienne ce qui
est clair c'est qu'il ya une différence
entre l'attitude que le gouvernement
affichait autour de la table et les
premières déclarations qui le fait la
sortir de son conseil général surtout
monsieur charest qui devance ses
militants étaient très très confiants
entrée triomphante ce qu'il avait réussi
à régler la crise et qu'il martelait l'a
fermement que la hausse des frais de
scolarité resterait en place coûte que
coûte il ce n'était pas ce qu'on me dit
on tourne à tort parce qu'elle est
restée à la frustre un peu les gens qui
se sont fait présenter cette fois comme
un compromis et là on se retourne dans
les médias on entend premier ministre et
riant fans des espèces ont pris enfants
qui disent qu'ils ont vaincu le
mouvement étudiant c'est un peu
particulier